[Applaudissements]
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez vous
dire en colère il n'a pas voulu que je
lui étais une sa flamme il a pris le
bras comme ça la main de moundir face à
mon petit bras flux et je fais mais
autant vous dire que je les ai sentis
prêts c'est encore la marque la grâce à
ce moment là la seule chose que j'ai
trouvée parce qu'il me dit non non non
non je veux bien que tu étais des
flammes mais on va dans la forêt
imaginez c'est comme ce plateau là il ya
quand même huit ou neuf caméras on peut
pas partir dans la forêt comme ça en
freestyle
il perd 2,6 à lui faire c'est trouver
une idée pour qu'ils puissent accepter
que j'éteigne sa flamme je me suis dit
tiens là tu es dos aux aventuriers et
ont éliminé si je te mettais de face rfi
vous allez être face à ceux qui vous ont
éliminé et l'allemagne est d'accord et
ça et ça c'est dans le bouquin ça fait
deux